SVET GANOV: Hi, everybody.
My name is Svet Ganov.
I'm the tech lead for the
Android runtime permission
model.
I'm the TL for Android
printing accessibility.
I worked on various
other things.
JEFF SHARKEY: My
name is Jeff Sharkey.
I'm a software engineer on
the Android framework team,
and I've worked on
things like SD cards,
package management, and parts
of the networking stack.
Today Svet's going to dig into
permissions and how they've
evolved in Marshmallow,
and then I'll
be back up to talk
about best practices.
Svet?
SVET GANOV: Thank you, Jeff.
So before I begin
my talk, you're
probably wondering, what
are these permissions?
What is he going to
be talking about?
Before I get into the nuts
and bolts of permissions
and how the new runtime
permission model works,
I want to cover the very basics.
What is a permission?
A permission controls
access to sensitive data.
For example, my contacts,
SMS, and critical resources.
Critical resources
are, for example,
the camera and the GPS.
Permissions are granted to
applications by the user,
and there are two
different protection
levels of provisions.
One of them is normal,
dangerous, and signature.
Normal permissions
are considered
not that harmful to the user,
and applications usually
get them immediately as
soon as they are installed.
They don't need user approval.
Dangerous permissions are
more critical to the user,
and these are things
like your contacts,
your camera, and
location, which require
the user to opt in and
allow the application
to use the information.
There is a third
type of permission
which is called
signature permissions.
Signature permissions
are defined
by an application
or the platform,
and in order for
another application
to get this permission,
it has to be signed
with the same certificate.
This pretty much means
that it should be developed
by the same developer.
I'm going to do a very quick
dive on how permissions used
to work before on L, and pre-M
devices in general before I
dive into the new
permission model.
So what probably most of
you know, on the L devices
you just go to the Play Store.
You find an application
you want to install.
You see the familiar
Install button.
You click the Install
button, and you
see this nice list of
all the permissions
that the application is using.
You have basically two
options at this point--
accept operations or go back.
And even if you don't like
one of those permissions
and if you have some
doubts, you basically
have still these two options,
like opt in or completely don't
install the application at all.
Assume that I approve
all permissions.
The application gets
downloaded, I open the app,
and the application can
be used all the time.
So the old permission model
had several limitations.
For one, the user
had no control.
Basically you have
the big hammer.
You add or keep the
nail or you don't.
It's basically you add or accept
all permissions and install
the app or you don't.
There is no context
for the user.
Why does this application
use permissions?
So you're probably asking,
why is a flashlight
app asking for some permission?
There's probably a
good reason for that,
but the thing is that it's
not obvious every time
why the applications
uses certain permissions.
Another problem we had was
we had too many permissions,
and it was really hard to
make an informed choice when
you have 30 options and
you need to understand
30 different concepts
to decide what to do.
Another problem is
the technical jargon
that was used by the explanation
for certain permissions,
mainly because it's
been evolving over time,
and we've been adding
more and more concepts,
and to be honest, I am an
engineer working on this,
and still it was kind of hard to
understand all the permissions
at some point.
I just needed to look it
up and see what it was.
And the other issue,
which is really
important for you guys
who have developers
is that there was
friction on upgrade,
because if you get an
update for the application
and require a new
permission, the user has
to explicitly approve it
before the upgrade occurs.
This is problematic, because
many times developers
are afraid to add new
features because they
may require a new permission.
This can limit the options
of the application,
and this could lead to the
other pathological case where
you request all
permissions up front,
just in case-- you
don't even know.
So in order to solve
all these problems,
I'm presenting how permissions
work on M, or Mash model.
What we did is, we realized that
we had too many permissions,
and we decided to
group the permissions
into nine permission groups
which are oriented by topic.
This is what we
present to the user
when they manage
the permissions.
So if the user grants you
the contacts permission,
they under the hood grant
you all the permissions
in the contacts group.
All the permissions are runtime,
so there is no permission UI
when you install the app.
So if you go to the Play Store
and find your application,
you see the Install
button, then click Install,
and the installation
starts right away.
You don't see any UI, any
dialogues for permissions,
and you can open the app.
When the application
needs permissions,
it does present them at runtime.
This is one example of
how the calendar app is
asking for your contacts.
The idea behind this
permission model
is that the user has
more context for what
the permission is needed
for, because you're
trying to use a feature, you're
trying to use the camera,
and when you try
to use the feature,
it's asking for the
camera permissions.
It's pretty obvious why
the permission is needed,
and you have more contacts
and more informed choices.
The other benefit of
the new permission model
is that you can always
change your mind.
You can say, hey, I granted
this app this permission,
but I don't feel comfortable for
the app to use this permission.
You can always go to
Settings and change that.
Or you have access to
permissions by application,
so now we can see
all the permissions
that the Hangouts app is using.
So which apps are
using this permission?
For example, which apps
are using the camera
permission on my device?
You can control that.
This is how modern
applications work.
The application has to
be explicitly written
to use the new
runtime permission
model, which is probably 0.1% of
the applications from the Play
Store.
You're probably
asking yourself, what
do I do for all the 99.9%
of the applications?
How do they work?
Because the way
they're written, they
don't expect permissions
to be revoked on them.
So if you revoke the
permission on an app,
it will just blindly call the
API, and it will just crash.
The way permissions
work for legacy apps
is you go to the
Play Store again,
you find the application,
you click the Install button,
you see the familiar
permissions dialog,
and again you have two options.
You either accept all
permissions or you go back.
The difference, though, is when
you install the application
and accept all permissions,
now you can go to Settings,
and you can manage permissions
for those applications,
even though they don't support
the new runtime permission
model.
Then the question is, again,
you have the nine permission
groups, so from this
point on, for you,
the application is controlling
permissions for legacy
and non-legacy apps is
absolutely the same.
There is no difference.
And then the question is
how did you guys do this?
The way we do it is, instead
of revoking permissions
for legacy applications,
we're just disabling the API.
We're using a feature
called app-ops.
Probably some of you
are familiar with it.
And what we do is
literally-- for example,
you revoke the
contacts permission.
The application really
has contacts permission.
We don't revoke the
permission, but what
we do is, when the application
is asking for contacts,
we say, sorry no
contacts on the device.
So we're basically
making the APIs
do nothing or return default
errors or empty data sets.
It's case-dependent,
so we basically
had to visit all
the APIs and just
make them work appropriately.
How do you ask for permission?
Before I go into the nuts and
bolts of how to do it in code,
I really want to cover the UX,
because it's really, really
important to have a
consistent experience
for all applications.
It's good for the user,
it's good for you,
It's good for the ecosystem,
it's good for everyone.
You can imagine a
two-dimensional matrix.
So in one dimension you have
how important this permission
is for my application.
Is it critical, or is
it an optional feature?
So for example, if
I have a camera app,
the camera permission
is critical for my app.
It will not work if I don't
have the camera permission.
However, location is
a different story.
Maybe I have a
geotagging feature,
but most users probably
don't understand
how location is related to
photos, and in this case,
I probably don't need this
permission right away.
It's not critical for
my application to work.
Also, it's about context.
The other dimension of
this matrix is the context.
So is it clear to the user
why you need the permission,
or is it not clear?
And based on that, I'll
cover all the cases
and what the UX recommendation
is in each of use cases.
So Case 1.
Assume that it's a
critical permission
that your application needs,
but it's not clear to the user
why you need this permission.
So that's a great
opportunity for you
to have a warm welcome
screen, where you present
the core features
for your application
and how to use the application,
and you educate the user.
In this context.
it will be clear to the user
why this permission is needed,
and at the end of this
flow, you can just literally
request a permission,
and the user
will not be wondering why you
need this permission at all.
The second pattern
is asking up-front.
If you have an application that
really needs this permission
and it's very obvious--
the camera app
is a perfect example.
You have a camera, you
need the camera permission,
and without the
camera permission,
the application cannot work.
So for the user
it's not a surprise
if you ask for the
camera permission.
They just downloaded
the camera app.
The third case is for
secondary features
where it's obvious why
you need this permission.
For example, let's pick
the geotagging example
that I gave you
a minute earlier.
If I have a photo and I
select to geotag the photo,
and I'm asked for a
location permission,
I wouldn't be surprised.
It's obvious to me.
I can see in the
context that I know
why this permission is needed.
The fourth pattern is
educate in context.
This is for cases where
it's a secondary feature
for the application, and
it's unclear to the user.
you really shouldn't
have features
that fall into this
bucket, but in case you do,
you can explain before you
request the permission.
You can educate
the user on why you
need this permission before
you ask for the permission.
We even have a dedicated API,
which has this long name show
request permission rationale,
that you can use as a hint
whether to show a
permission rationale.
I'll cover this in
detail a bit later.
What I forgot to mention
that's really important
is that when you ask for a
permission the very first time,
the user does two options--
accept the permission
or deny the permission.
They do not have the option
to say don't ask me again.
So the very first
time it's safe to ask.
The second time,
the user says no,
but the application keeps
asking for the same permission.
Now the user has the option
to say don't ask me again.
So the very first time
you save, that's a very
important message-- just ask
for the permission up front.
There is a fifth pattern
which I would say
is more like an anti-pattern.
I've been asked this
question many times,
so that's why I decided to
bring it up to your attention.
But to be honest,
from all the Google
Apps that were seeing
this as a problem,
nobody actually had to
implement this pattern,
and there was another
way around that.
That's the case where
you have a service,
it runs in the background,
and you don't have UI,
the user's not using the
UI of your application,
and now you need a permission.
So what do you do?
We don't have APIs to request
permissions from services,
and that's on purpose,
because we don't
want to interrupt the user.
So definitely, when the
user is using another app,
you shouldn't throw
an activity in front
of them asking for
the permission,
because this is
disrupting the user flow.
What you should do is first
avoid this if possible,
and the other is just post
a notification and say,
hey, this feature won't work.
When the user has time, they
can open the notification.
When they click on
the notification,
you should bring
a full screen UI
where you can explain
what feature needs
this permission, what is
this permission used for,
and let the user choose
whether they want to opt in,
and at which point you can
request permission or opt out.
So here are the
permissions APIs.
There are just a few
APIs you need to learn.
They're very, very simple.
I really want to have
this message that
is very, very, very simple
to use for permissions.
The first API is very simple.
Do I have this
permission, which means
does my app have the
permission, not somebody who's
calling for a remote process.
The second API is to
request the permission.
As you can see,
we have these APIs
on Activity
[INAUDIBLE] Fragments.
Once you request
a permission, you
need an API,
because a permission
request is asynchronous.
This brings a UI, and the
user has to decide what to do.
That's why you have this
call-back on permission result
request on a request
permissions result where
you need to handle the result
of what the user decided to do.
The last two APIs are a little
non-obvious as to what they do.
They should show
permission rationale.
This API it has
very targeted use,
and it's intended for--
so this returns true if
and only if the user already
declined the permission once.
You requested a permission, the
user saw the UI and said no.
And now you can
use this API that's
a hint whether--
maybe the user did not
have enough context when
they requested the permission
the previous time.
So you can help the user and
show this additional education
and additional screen to explain
why you need the permission.
But again, this
is very optional,
and this is only if you
feel that the user doesn't
have enough context.
We really think that most of the
time this shouldn't be needed,
but in case you do, it's there.
There is another case where
you can have device policy that
says, no, this application
does not have this permission,
and it cannot get it.
The way to read this API, is
permission revoked by policy,
is does the user have the power
to give me the permission?
If The user doesn't
have the power
to give you the permission,
you may not even
expose the feature, or you
can explain to the user
that the feature is not
developed because the policy
doesn't allow this permission.
Now that we have all
the building blocks,
here is how we
put them together.
It's really important
that the very first thing
you need to do when you call
a permission-protected API
is to always, always
first check whether you
have the permission.
If you have the permission,
just go ahead and do the work.
If you don't have
the permission,
now you can optionally check
should I show rationale,
should I help the
user better understand
why I need this permission,
because the user already
declined the permission.
Otherwise, you just go ahead
and request the permission.
Once you request
the permission, you
need to handle the result
based on what the user decided.
This is what permission
result handling looks like.
The first thing
you need to check
is, is this the request I made,
like is this the answer I'm
waiting for.
If that's the case,
the next check
is, is there information
in the answer,
so are these arrays with
permissions and results empty.
They're usually empty if
there is a cancellation.
The next thing I check is,
did I get the permission.
If you get the permission,
go do the work.
So it's all great.
How do you get on the boat?
How do you get on the train?
How do you opt in to a
new permission model?
It's based on the target
SDK, so what you need to do
is change your target SDK
to 23, and magically, you
use the new API and you're
in the new permission model.
It's important to note
that there is no way out.
Once you get in, you cannot
go back to target SDK, say 22.
This main reason for
that is that we really
believe that runtime permissions
are really good for the user,
they're really good
for developers,
they're good for the
ecosystem, and we really
want to incentivize everybody to
use this new permission model.
We have these very
special cases which
I want to point out,
very, very useful APIs.
One of them is say
you have a new feature
that you want to use.
You want to add a camera feature
only for M devices and up.
You don't want to request
a camera permission,
because this can affect your
adoption on all the platforms.
So what you can do is hey, I
want to use this permission,
but only on platforms that
support runtime permissions.
So use this permission.
SDK 23 is your friend.
We have another way of
requesting permissions up
to a given SDK.
So you say, I want this
permission up to L. The way
you do it is you specify max
SDK version in the user's
permission API,
in your manifest.
Upgrades-- what it
the upgrading story?
Permissions are grandfathered,
so if you have an L app on an L
device, you have
all the permissions,
and if the device
gets updated to M,
your application still
has all the permissions,
with the caveat that the
user can go ahead and revoke
the permissions.
If you upgrade your application
from target SDK 22 to 23
to opt into the new
permission model,
you still keep your permissions.
Also revoke permissions.
If I install a legacy
app targeting L SDK,
and if I revoke some
permissions as a user, when
I get the update,
the same permissions
are still revoked until I go
ahead and run them explicitly.
We support library APIs.
I will not go into details,
but the message here
is for all the APIs
that you saw in the SDK,
there are corresponding APis
in the Support v4 library,
so you can use permissions
from the support library.
We also have APIs in
Support library v13
if you don't want
to go back to v4.
And this is kind of an
edge case which I really
wanted to point out for
proxying permissions.
This is again a very edge case.
Usually this happens
when I have an app that
has access to contacts,
and I decorate contacts,
for every contact, I'm adding
a Smiley face, for example.
I have the contacts
permission, and I have access
to all the contacts, but if an
app is asking me, hey, give me
the Smiley face contact,
I need to verify
whether this application
has the contacts
permission in first
place, because I don't
want to be leaking the contacts
permission without user
approval.
It's really important to
use the permission-checker
from the v4 Support
library to do this,
because it checks not
only the permission,
but it also checks whether
the APIs are enabled.
If you remember, for
legacy applications
we don't revoke permissions,
we disable the APIs.
So the permission checker knows
how to check the permission
and whether the APIs
are disabled by checking
the corresponding app-ops.
There are some command line
tools that are very useful.
One of them is adb
shell pm grant/revoke.
You can use this to grant or
revoke permissions to an app.
During development
this is very useful.
Instead of having to manually
approve the permission
every time, you can literally
grant and revoke permissions
from the command line.
Another thing that's very
useful for a developer
is if you want to
install the application
with all permissions
granted, you
use the familiar adb install
with the dash g, which
means grant all
permissions, specify
the package and the APK, and
all permissions are granted.
Sometimes it's useful to dump
the state for your application.
Adb shell dumps the
package, and then
the package name dumps
the state of your package
in the PackageManager, and it
also lists all the permissions.
We also have some
device policy APIs.
This is very for people who
write device policy, which
is fairly rare, but there
is a way for you to specify,
hey, this permission for
this app is always granted
or it's always denied.
Or you can say, hey, for
every subsequent request,
I want permissions to
be automatically denied
or automatically approved.
Some dos and don'ts.
Please never code around
permission groups.
Don't assume that if you have
one permission in one group,
you have the other
permissions in the same group.
We reserve the right-- because
at the application level,
you operate in that the role
individual permission level.
And the user controls the
permissions at the group level.
So it's a simplification
for the user.
But please don't assume
any grouping behavior.
We want to reserve the right to
add new permission groups, move
permissions between groups.
I'm not saying we will
do it, but it's just
for the flexibility
of the platform.
Also avoid screening questions.
Hey, if I ask you
for this permission,
are you going to give
me this permission?
We want you to ask up front,
because the first time there
is no penalty.
There is no don't ask
again option for the user
if you ask for the
very first time.
Also follow the UX patterns.
It's really important that
all the applications are
consistent, it's good for
users, it's good for you,
it's good for everybody.
I want to stress again check
before you call an API that
is protected by a permission.
Don't assume that you
have the permission,
or don't rely on
some previous checks.
And this applies for any API,
it's not only for permissions.
But don't infer
undocumented behavior,
don't rely on
because we may
accidentally change that,
and we may accidentally
break your applications.
We are trying really hard
to be backwards-compatible,
but sometimes it's hard.
And probably we
have the question,
how do I know which APIs are
protected by permissions, which
is an interesting question.
It was never documented.
You can use Android
Studio, actually.
Android Studio is
flagging if you
call an API without
checking for permission.
With this asterisk that not all
APIs are probably annotated,
we have this special
annotation on the API
which permissions
are guarding it.
So in some cases, it may have
some misses, but we're trying
to get it better and better.
So with that, I'm
tossing over to Jeff
to talk about how not
to use permissions.
JEFF SHARKEY: Sven
just explained to us
the new runtime
permissions model
in M, how things changed
and evolved there,
and these powerful
new permission
groups that we have that
you can request from users.
But I'm going to shift gears
and talk about how you as an app
developer can actually
ask the user for fewer
permissions over time.
So as an example, again, we have
these permission categories.
There are nice and
shiny, but some of them
can be pretty broad and scary.
You as a developer
are asking the user
to give you access to
all of their contacts,
to all of the files that
they have on their SD card,
including all the photos that
they've taken in the past.
Some of these permissions
may make sense for your app.
Again, if you're
building that camera app,
you need access to the camera
permission to make that happen.
But other times you may be
asking for more than you need.
So that's what
we're going to do.
We're going to go
through a couple
of these common categories.
We're going to look at use
cases, common use cases
that you as an app
developer may have,
and we're going to look
at ways to still build
those parts of your
application without requesting
the big, broad,
scary permissions.
So the first one we'll
dig into is storage.
You'll probably
recognize this as read
or write external storage if
you've added these permissions
to your manifest.
And when you ask the
user for this permission
and they grant it,
the user is giving you
access to all of the
files on their card.
Even if you as an app
developer are not interested,
you're still requesting and
getting access to all of that.
Some common use
cases as a developer
is you might just be
looking for a place
to store additional data.
You're trying to be helpful.
You don't want to
take up the user's
valuable internal storage space.
You want to put that content
out on an SD card, maybe
a 33- or 64-gig card
that the user's inserted.
A second use case is maybe
you want the user to pick
individual files to work with.
If you're a photo
editor app, maybe
just want to open
the one or two files
that you want the
user to work with,
and you're not interested
in all those other details.
So let's dig into the details.
For that first example,
there are a handful of APis
that were introduced
in KitKat on context,
called getExternalFileDirs,
CachdDirs, and MediaDirs.
When you call these, the
paths that are returned
exist on the SD card, but
they have your package name
burned into them.
So if you look at
the bottom, you
can see the example of what
those returned paths look like.
Notice it would be under the SD
card/Android/data/your package
name.
There are a couple
reasons for that.
First of all, that's how the
system recognizes who that data
belongs to, so that it can
give you access to that data.
The paths that are
returned from these APIs--
your application always
has read and write
access to any contents
under those directories.
You're free to create new
directories and new files
at any time, and there
are no permissions
required to do that.
You don't need to request those
read or write permissions.
They still work even if
you have those permissions,
but you don't need
to request them.
The other benefit here is that
there's better accountability.
As the user goes to
uninstall your application,
the system will automatically
clean up any files
that you've chosen to
store in those locations.
In addition, if the
user goes into Settings
to see where their disk
space is being used,
it will be accounted against
your application correctly.
So it's better for a lot
of different reasons.
The next example
that we talked about
was just looking to pick
an individual file or work
with a handful of files.
This is where I'd
like to take a second
to talk about the
Storage Access Framework.
This is something that
we built in KitKat,
and it's really an
abstraction layer between apps
that offer to store files
or data, say like an SD card
or a Google Drive in
the cloud, and apps
that offer to work
with content or files,
say a document editor
or a photo editor.
In this case, instead
of asking the user
for those broad
permissions, asking
for all of the files
on their SD card
or all of the contents
of their Google Drive,
you as an app developer
are able to launch
a handful of common intents
that go into the Storage Access
Framework, and ask the data
what files would the user like
to work with.
They're given that
freedom to choose
which things they want to
return an access to your app.
The handful of intents
that are interesting
here are Open Document, Create
Document, and Get Content.
You can think of those
essentially like an open file
dialog box save file and
more of like an attached
file, if you're building
like an email application.
And will dig into it in a
moment, and a little bit
about how that works
under the hood.
Another thing to mention
is in Marshmallow,
we added access to USB
OTG, or On-The-Go devices.
So if you have a USB
flash drive that you've
plugged into your
device, those are now
available through the
Storage Access Framework.
So you as an app developer, if
you were using these intents,
you didn't have to add any
additional code to start
working with those devices.
They automatically appeared.
And that's true of a
cloud storage provider
or any other storage medium.
If they participate in the
Storage Access Framework,
there's no additional
work that you
need to do as an app
developer, and it gives users
more freedom and flexibility.
Then you might ask the
question, how does this-- here's
an example, actually.
We'll take a look at
just some of that UI
around that experience.
These are those three intents,
Open Document, Create Document,
and Get Content.
One thing to point out here
is that we're giving users
a consistent experience when
they go to pick these files.
You could build your
own UI for navigating
the contents of the SD
card, but as the user comes
into your app,
they're going to have
to understand how you've
chosen to represent some
of those concepts,
and it'll be slightly
different from every
other time they've
encountered that before.
But by using these
common intents,
we're giving a UI that
the user has probably
seen a couple of other
times on the platform.
They're already familiar
with how to navigate and use,
to navigate and pick the files
that they're interested in,
and this is beneficial
for the user,
because they can get the
task that they want to do--
they can get that done faster.
They understand how to
interact with this framework.
Now let's dig a little
bit deeper under the hood.
How does Storage Access
Framework actually work?
I'll talk a little bit
about URI permission grants.
All of the stuff we
talked about earlier today
is focusing on traditional
Android permissions, which
are a string, like
android.permission.READ
EXTERNAL STORAGE.
That's something that your
app requests in your manifest,
and when the user
grants that access,
you're granted that for the rest
of the lifetime of your app,
either until the
user uninstalls you,
or until the user
goes into Settings
and revokes that permission.
URI permission
grants are slightly
different in that
they're centered
around content providers.
So a content provider surfaces
its content on the system
through a URI, a
content://, an authority,
and then a path name.
And the power here
with URI permissions
is that we can grant access
to a very specific path
inside of a content provider
for a limited amount of time.
So, for example, if I just
took a photo in my app
and I want to share
it with someone else,
I can extend access
to just that photo
that I just took to the
receiving app at the other end,
temporarily.
The lifetime of that permission
is until that activity
stack finishes.
So I extend them
access, maybe I'm
sharing it as part of a social
network, they get access,
they can see the data that they
need to get their job done,
and as soon as the user
leaves that activity stack,
the permission is revoked.
So they only have access to
the data that they needed
and for a very limited time.
You might be asking
the question,
how do I wire this
up inside my app?
And one of the easiest ways
to do that is using a class
called FileProvider in
the Support library.
That allows you as a
developer to easily convert.
If you have a file on
disk, you can convert it
into one of these content
URIs that then you
can stick into just
a traditional intent
that you might already
be using today.
In this case there is
an Intent.ACTION_SEND,
send and instead of
using a file URI,
we're sending a content
URI to the other side,
and that's what allows us to
use that additional flag there,
Intent.FLAG GRANT
READ URI PERMISSION.
This is you as an app developer
communicating to the system
that you want to extend
temporary access to that URI
to whoever receives
it at the other end.
One of the reasons
this is becoming
more important in Marshmallow
is that you may not
know-- whoever's at the
receiving end may not
have that storage
permission, or they may not
have the permissions to
access that content outright.
So this is your way of
making sure that whoever's
at the receiving end has
the permissions that they
need to access the
content under the hood.
So in summary, even if
you're using file URIs,
you'll want to look at
transitioing them, even in M,
more towards using these content
URIs because of the power
that comes from them.
And there's a
StrictMode API that you
can use to help track
down in your application
if there are places where you
might still be using file URIs.
You can turn on that
StrictMode, and it will log it,
and you can quickly figure out
if there are any places that
are still lingering around.
All right, so we've
talked about storage.
Let's go into another category.
Let's talk about Phone.
A couple of permissions
that fall into that category
are READ_PHONE_STATE
and CALL_PHONE.
These are pretty powerful
too, when you think about it.
They give you access to see
the user's phone number,
to see their IMEI, to read the
current state of the phone,
are they in a phone call or not.
In reality, you may have
a couple common use cases,
like, for example, you're
just interested in using
the IMEI as a unique identifier,
to be able to figure out
which device is this.
Or you may just want
to initiate a phone
call, to start a call
to a specific phone
number for the user.
Let's look at that first
example, and I'll say,
don't use IMEI as a unique
identifier on the device.
The reality is not all
devices have a telephone stack
in the first place.
Most tablets out
there, for example.
If you need some
sort of identifier,
you can always
build one yourself.
You can use, like,
java.util.UUID
and Persistent locally
in your app data storage,
and then communicate
that with your server
when you are
interacting with it.
Another alternative
is the Instance ID
that's provided through
Google Play services.
That's also useful.
It provides a unique
identifier that then you
would use if you're
integrating with Google Cloud
Messaging, for example.
Second of all, if you're looking
for that unique identifier
for managing app
licenses, there's
also a solution in Play.
The Play Licensing is another
alternative to look at there.
So the takeaway is
please don't use IMEI,
because it's not really as
useful as you think it is.
For that second example
of making a phone call,
there's are two intents
here that are interesting.
There's a slight
nuance between the two.
There's ACTION_CALL
and ACTION_DIAL.
When you send an
ACTION_CALL call intent,
you're actually taking
the phone off the hook,
dialing the number, and it
starts ringing for the user.
They'll hear the
actually ringing
as it initiates the phone call.
ACTION_DIAL, on the other hand,
simply launches the dialer
activity, the UI, and
inserts the number.
It types the number in, the
phone number you want to call,
but it doesn't
actually initiate it.
It waits for the user
to click a button
to confirm that
they actually want
to initiate that phone call.
The difference
between those two is
that the ACTION_CALL requires
the CALL_PHONE permission.
If you use ACTION_DIAL, you'll
get that same functionality.
You're helping
the user short-cut
into making that phone call
that you know they to make,
but without requesting
that permission.
When you think about it, that
flow is a little awkward.
You're asking them for the
phone permission allow,
and then you're immediately
launching the phone call.
You think about using
ACTION_DIAL instead.
You launch them into
that familiar flow,
they click the Call button,
and they're on their way.
Here's just a quick example
of building up that tel:URI
and setting ACTION_DIAL.
Let's talk about the
Camera/Mic permissions.
When you request these,
you're requesting full access
to the camera and
microphone from now
on, when in reality
maybe you're just
interested in taking a photo
or a small video for the user
just for this moment
in time-- maybe,
for example, a
picture of a check
that the user just wrote
that they want to cash.
So it's really just some of
the common one-off use cases,
and you may not need that
permission all the time
going into the future.
And there are some nice intents
that can help you out here.
On MediaStore, there's
ACTION_IMAGE_CAPTURE and
VIDEO_CAPTURE.
One of the biggest
benefits here is
that you're launching the user
into a consistent experience.
If you were to request
the camera permission
and build your own
UI, and then you
need to represent advanced
features like turning
the flash on and off, or
turning on other camera features
and functionality,
you're probably
going to do that
in a different way,
using a different UI
than the user is used to.
The camera app that's
built into their phone
may represent it
one way, and then
you're giving them a
slightly different UI that
will take them a longer
time to get used to find out
where are all the
additional features
and functionality that they're
used to having access to,
so by using these
intents, you're
actually launching into
the built-in camera
app on the system, the one
that the user has chosen,
where they've
probably already taken
dozens of photos in the past.
They're already familiar
with how to choose
the advanced functionality.
So it's making the user
experience faster for them.
They're able to jump right
in, they understand the flow
and how to use it, and then
they get the content back
that they need.
The one thing that I will
mention here is you may think,
well, I'll try requesting
the camera permission,
and if the user
denies me, then I'll
fall back to using
some of these intents.
That's
Something we don't
want to encourage.
If you need the full
camera experience,
ask for the camera
permission and make sure
that the user either
allows or denies
it, and don't try falling back.
Go for the one that you want.
If you really need the full
camera permission, ask for it.
Or if you don't need the
full camera permission,
just use one of these intents.
The reality is that if
you ask for the camera
permission and the
user denies you,
and then if you try using
one of these intents,
the system will throw a
security exception at you,
so this is purposely.
We want to have you focus on
either one path or the other.
Contacts permission--
let's talk about those.
Redirect contacts.
And again, this is accessing
all the user's contacts, all
the people that they've
added over the years, when
in reality you may only be
interested in just reading
one contact.
You want to share
something with one person.
Or maybe you just want to add a
little bit of additional detail
to an existing contact,
maybe a new email address.
So we'll dig into two quick
examples related to those.
First there's ACTION_PICK.
You can launch that ACTION_PIC
intent and ask the user,
pick me a contact and in
return the access back.
Under the hood, this using
the same URI permission
grants that we talked
about a few moments ago.
When you launched towards the
system asking the user to pick,
whatever item that they
pick, that contact, that URI,
is returned to you with
temporary permission,
that you can read
just that contact.
You won't be able to see
any of the other contacts,
but just the one
the user selected.
Here's that quick example,
and there are more details
if you go to the link there
for the contacts provider,
to see how that
works under the hood.
On the flip side, creating
or editing a contact,
there's an intent for that.
Here you provide just
information that you know.
You know their phone
number, their name,
or their email address, and
you give the user the choice.
Maybe they want to create
a brand-new contact
for this person, or maybe
this contact already exists,
and you're just
augmenting and adding
a little bit of extra details
that weren't in there before.
This you're launching
towards the contacts
up on the platform, and the
user is the one left in control.
They can make the choice of
what to do, create a new one
or edit an existing.
Similarly here,
you're giving them
a familiar contact-editing
experience,
something that they've
already interacted
with on the phone, a URI
that they're familiar with.
Calendar permission--
again, it's
accessing all of the
user's calendar events,
when in reality you may just
want to add one upcoming event,
say, for example, this talk
that we're in right now.
Here's an example
of how to do that.
There's an ACTION_INSERT
intent for that.
We can fill in some
of the details,
say, like, when it
starts and ends,
and the details around it, and
then just start that activity.
We don't require the
right calendar event.
We launch into a
UI, and fill out
the fields, ready
for the user taste
to say, yes, I want to
save, and persist that.
So we're adding that
additional functionality
without requiring
that permission.
So in summary, we talked about
how permissions and Marshmallow
are much more powerful
now, but at the same time,
the user has the power to
deny us access as developers.
They can say no.
So what I would say
is carefully consider
when you are asking
for those permissions,
and consider using
some of the strategies
that we just talked
about to build your apps,
without having to ask for those
permissions in the first place,
in a way that you can
still accomplish the goal,
build the app that you want to
build with the functionality
that you need,
but without asking
for those broad permissions.
And finally, we talked
about those intent patterns,
so the intents where the user
is given a common, familiar UI,
so they have a
consistent experience ,
and they're able to accomplish
whatever they're trying to do
faster.
So hopefully you have a
better picture of Marshmallow
and how the permissions
have evolved.
Svet and I will be available.
We're running out of time.
We'll be available at office
hours later this evening
if you have questions
for either of us.
But without that,
thanks for your time.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]